so we got but today we got together
earlier to work on a thing mm-hmm
and it's actually [ __ ] cool because
you know we sit here all the time and be
like you know talk about cool [ __ ] cool
IP that exists and they're making [ __ ]
from and then periodically he makes that
[ __ ] better by going they should have
done this and you're like [ __ ] that
sounds good and I always say like I want
someone giving you a TV show and then I
always go like us as well I hitch my
wagon to his storage we should get a
show yeah we why don't we have a [ __ ]
show we got a show you got a show and
you were like hey you wanna come play I
was well then I was like I can't do a
show without he I listen to him improve
shows all the time and I've never been a
guy that's worked to writers room and
not because I'm against it I've just
always in the India's alone right so
I've always been the one guy writing by
himself one time on clerks the cartoon
we had a writers room that was so [ __ ]
up it was weird to have people like you
pitch an idea no like I don't know and
I'm like I [ __ ] invented cloaks oh
yeah I [ __ ] trust me this idea please
so generally speaking I didn't have that
experience so on this I was like oh my
god I get to play with a writers room
and I'm gonna learn how to do that and
I've listened to him talk about it so
often whatnot and sat here as he's like
talked about the process I was like of
course I'm gonna [ __ ] yank him in
absolutely so it's it's a cool it's it's
a legit show the only reason we could
say we got a show is because like we
[ __ ] had an official meeting today
like checks have been signed big names
and [ __ ] it's [ __ ] crazy quick
somebody did I got though this is like
an internship like I'm a showing up for
credit it is it's we can't say what it
is right now because they haven't
released it yet and they talked about
today the when that's gonna happen and
it's imminent but ya know announce it
soon enough yes and and I mean San
Diego's come and I wouldn't be surprised
like if there's a time or whatever but
this it's a soap opera this is it's like
I need just to like put everyone at like
ease or whatever the [ __ ] it's it's not
like Marvel so don't be like oh my god
they're gonna [ __ ] up Marvel not at all
oh we love it too much I wouldn't go
over there yeah I mean we're gonna [ __ ]
up your childhood but not like your
favorite thing yes
but it's - good point Mia we are playing
with vary with time honored one would
say IP nostalgic IP for sure
IP that like it's it's fun it's
fantastic and and so we got into this
thing where you know today we sat around
with the writers me and Mark Eric who's
Eric Roscoe who's been on the show
who've worked on Supergirl
so and some other cat some of my
liberties that probably should even sit
but whatever so we sat around with our
boss and I can't tell you where the boss
is from but like it's a good place and
then our other bosses who I can't say
where they're from but like so a good
also a good [ __ ] place that if I said
the word you'd be like that's the sound
of a happy childhood
so so we all got together about 10 of us
in the living room today in this morning
from 9 a.m. to 1 to 1 o'clock breaking
story coming up with essentially what we
were we were doing I should let me limit
it's not movie it's a series I said we
got a show yeah listen we can't talk
that much about it because I told my
current bosses that I had a doctor's
appointment x-ray done or something like
don't mind me I'll be back by 1:00 ish
so yeah like this just blew up my
[ __ ] spot now sorry
I'd like to invent another grandparent
to die for the next time he hits again I
don't know I didn't know that you're
lying to your employers and [ __ ] like
that doesn't really [ __ ] make your
new employer feel very good about things
like oh he's a liar I see it's it's what
I do for the passion is true we do live
for a living doing it's a cool thing and
we'll be able to talk about it very soon
but to be fair like it's it's very big
very big it's much bigger than us
and so many work in so many [ __ ] ways
and we're having this like grand old
time with it getting to do stuff with it
that hasn't really been done before and
stuff it's it's a total fan service
project one could say yeah it's it's
it's been sweet so anyway we got to sit
down in room today and like after all
this time of sitting next to them and
hearing what he does in the writers room
and stuff I got to see him in the
writers room and he was [ __ ] magic
man like it was really dope like there
were
there were no less than five moments
where our employer who is a [ __ ]
awesome dude like like I and I'm gonna
just saying this because they gave us a
job I've worked for many people and not
really said this like this guy makes it
fun to go to work he is so [ __ ]
passionate he's he's an exec but he's
might as well be one of the [ __ ]
writers um he came up with like
fantastic ideas and [ __ ] mark five times
no less than five times over the course
of the those from nine to one
our boss was just like oh that's awesome
everyone said yeah that's awesome that's
awesome that's awesome it was dope man
it was really cool I felt a sense of
like pride even though like I didn't
have the idea but I was like I know him
because I told him to come here tea he's
fresh ideas are kind of mine he brought
his poison I'm putting my name on them
oh my god it was fun so after all this
time I'm sitting around talking about
like man I wish we got something you
want to think and I don't think we it's
it's moving very [ __ ] fast yeah way
faster than I'm accustomed yes which is
to be honest like a little like oh okay
like it's just I'm used to working him
out but it took me like [ __ ] three
years to get chainsaw Bob reboot made
these cats are like we released this
yesterday so finish it today
no they litter like under the bra
already they're like oh no we're not
gonna take our sweet time we're not even
gonna buy dinner we're just going
straight for it
third base [ __ ]
so weird to show you how like [ __ ]
married an old I am I was like under the
bronze that's some sort of movie
expression I'm unfamiliar and a second
to be like oh that's a sex thing oh
there it is
getting soft man so anyway it was great
you can be trim I can tell already in
action it was really really nice and I
can't wait to share it all with you
it's very germane to our world and the
things we talk about on this show in
fact if we didn't have this job we would
have probably been talking about whoever
got this job and been like hope they
don't [ __ ] it up yes up so easy now
people will say that about us the circle
of life yes alright so there's that
there's another thing I wanted to talk
about I've all this stuff I brought
there was a bag - where's the bag just
the bag yes so you know we get we get he
gets I get stuff they send like you know
premiums whatever the [ __ ] talk about
I'm you're a tastemaker if I can you
hear [ __ ] like fluent some [ __ ] and
we've bought stuff on the show like for
Black Panther they gave me iced tea I
know like it was brisk guys ten I got
tablet and it had a [ __ ] iPad or not
iPad but like a tablet and the idea is
like hey can you talk about this Black
Panther movie we don't know if anyone's
seen it so it's always so strange man
but I'm a fan of the things so I've like
number one I'm happy to accept them
number two like you know it gives me
something to show off here and talk
about here and stuff so a couple
premiums I've received recently and this
is what of course they want you to do
with it show it off talk about it and
[ __ ] you what I get well we open up your
fence yes lootcrate sent me a pair of
metal straws feel like here this is for
your dirty cocaine
why why does I mean like did you talk
about straws I've never mentioned straws
in my entire life of other than like to
a waiter like can I have a straw that's
all I've ever said about straw I think
you've been profiled though like he's a
straw man well the [ __ ] is a straw thank
you but like now we live in the world
and which straws are now like an
endangered species so oh that's right so
they're like no it's for the environment
we're helping you take your own dirty
straws out and reuse them a lot and then
get like botulism or whatever and then
go home but we're saving the environment
right
so thanks look great what fancy ashes
did you get you're not gonna get
anything from blue Krait after that man
they're gonna be like what the [ __ ] we
sent you a metal straw jet tick this
came from
well obviously let's show it offers it's
a backpack yes and of course it has some
pins on it there's a branding on it as
well this is from the good folks of
Doritos who or what mark barnard and do
you think this this backpack would be
promoting I'm gonna say either Doritos
yes or far from home it is a spider-man
activation this is a backpack it's got
four different pins on it representing I
guess the four countries that they're in
over the course of the lure T so it
comes with some cool pins on it number
one so if you're spider-man fan holy
[ __ ] the Doritos tag tells you there
must be tasty goodness inside let's rip
this bad boy open and find out like what
this activation is if you remember we
once at Shazam sent me a [ __ ]
light-up sweater which Jamie got and I
thought of you as I got in the card
today because I have Captain Marvel
stuff for you which I just didn't grab
and stuff because I was grabbing a [ __ ]
but it's still there inside for you so
this they send you it comes with this
letter a barely a letter and it says
Doritos incognito Doritos that
the name of the spider-man promotion
Incognito's Doritos somewhere some
publicist is like [ __ ] wetting
themselves going like he even said the
name of the promotion the Novus round we
came up with till he's like he's the
ultimate pigeon contents under embargo
until June 19th is that today no
tomorrow oh all right well [ __ ] it at
10:00 a.m. Eastern Time that's kind of
like right now sure so keep it incognito
so the idea of course is like spider-man
is over there incognito what comes in
this incognito bag u.s. number-one
Doritos that most American of [ __ ]
foods man the pride of our great home
native land you had like a Dorito gun
that you could just fire it into the
crack I know right boom and before we go
for the big thing let's see is there
anything in there up front who was in
the up front pocket weed a [ __ ]
passport and on the back of the passport
there is a Doritos tag of course inside
it's branded like you wouldn't believe
there's a page of information Doritos
incognito Doritos you're now in
possession of incognito Doritos
spider-man teamed up with Doritos I
wonder if they know his secret identity
he's incognito yeah really
spider-man teamed up with the Doritos
R&D that would be research and
development I imagine to make a
revolutionary new bag that transforms
into his suit while the detail is this
wearable food is this like some Lady
Gaga [ __ ] hold on don't wanna yeah I
just
don't spoil it man [ __ ] you
impatient boys miss dessert while the
details are top-secret we've enlisted
you to test it out we recommend wearing
it in inconspicuous places like comic
conventions cosplay events or jury duty
okay certificate of authenticity this
certificate verifies the authenticity of
the limited-edition spider-man replica
suit created for Doritos and spider-man
far from home promotion this replica is
one of 185 worldwide
I got suit holy [ __ ] this is some signed
and numbered [ __ ] I was about to make
fun of it but this is dope Thank You
Murray toes this is gonna make fun of it
just you don't you can go ahead suit
number 77 out of 185 instructions to put
on the spider-man suit there's they're
not [ __ ] around open bag and gently
pull out suit so this is the bag gently
on the back or on the front it says
Doritos it's shaped roughly about the
size of a Dorito z-- bag but you
wouldn't feel that what would you say
that's made of canvas or something like
that uh this is made of this [ __ ] that
they make the bags at Comic Con out of
rap good call
absolutely all right so let's read the
instructions thank you that's I've been
working out all night it said there's
velcro on open bag and gently pull out
suit so sexual so it's a Velcro here
that velcro someone at Doritos right now
is he's doing it the way we always wish
somebody would do it like seventies born
holy [ __ ] like this is actually a
quality piece of merchandise man I mean
the eye pieces are nice Nate come on
hold this up on the other side of the
bar for everybody so they can see it
from head to toe hold on it's still
stuck in the bag
maybe meanwhile it says unzip underarm
zippers that's gonna be the next step
step into suit one leg at a time then
place arms and sleeves and pull mask
over a head do you think I can't Peter
Parker himself wrote these directions it
says open bag and gently pull out suit
so maybe gotta pull it
it was one of 185 now there you go wow
he's free it's broken but it's free good
luck Nate find a friend to flip the bag
upwards so that it lays flat on your
back pull the right underarm zipper down
to the left crush it back pull down and
left under we're gonna see if spider-man
is Jewish let's let's see the guy that's
actually like it looks like they spent a
few bucks man
turn around I show two cameras that
they're not off camera that you're just
show stand against the wall you know
yeah yeah yeah there you go
pull up the headpiece yeah [ __ ] man it's
not bad you slip in through the back
door can you put on the top half No is
it small that small it's at wing size
certainly not for husky lads
instructions to store the spider-man
suit in the bag lay the suit out flat
zip the underarms clothes hold the soles
of the feet together fold the rope oh
they tell you how to put it back in the
bag yeah then in the passport there are
a bunch of stamps to the places they go
in the movie presumably England Prague
London us italia italy germany venice
and european union in general so those
are all the places presumably they're
going in the mood it's a sweet little
cool passport and this what looks like a
plane ticket of course is from Fandango
use the Fandango promotional code code
below for two free movie tickets to
Spider Man far from home so they gave us
some free tickets one but it's also like
kind of dope because it looks like a
plane ticket at the top it says Peter
Parker someone a so like you get to keep
it to like you don't have to turn this
in you just you put in that code and you
get to hold on to this forever and then
one day you have kids and they're like
why do you still have this
which happens to me all the [ __ ] time
this is pretty dope man maybe we give
that away in terms of an activation I
mean the bags destroy by the way no it's
[ __ ] one of 185 we can give them
that's mine we give the movie ticket
away oh the movie ticket yeah maybe
we'll do that yeah I don't even know why
I'm keeping the suit I'll never [ __ ]
touch it again but I'm like spine it's
one of 185 the Jason Mewes and me
totally came out where I'm like mine
what else do we have
I did a cool event last week in the city
a gaming event with the good folks at
twitch Prime and it was called cabs day
off and we played pub G me and J and
Marty bro doors at devil's legend goalie
New Jersey Devils and Taylor Hall who's
a current legend or just one Martin the
heart Martin Brodeur well done I know a
hockey thing you do
this was the they gave me a controller
it's a brand that is what does it called
somebody who came in here knows the us
no hooks cough it's a scuf controller
and it says Cavs that Kevin's day off on
it and it's for I guess yes yes it's for
PlayStation really [ __ ] sweet man the
whole event was like faunas [ __ ] man we
got to sit around and play games online
with a bunch of people and you know
Jason plays games all the time he's
always doing playing fortnight and
inviting people to come play with him
and stuff when we you know would have
opened the game to like the general
public they gave him the code to the
server we're on so the room fills up and
they know that we're playing [ __ ]
everybody just focuses all of the gun
power on killing Jason booze as quickly
as [ __ ] possible watch him in here and
get so frustrated come on let me play
it barely hits the ground though it's
like ah it was really it's fun [ __ ]
time though this is the trade paperback
of my miniseries Hit Girl
all four issues are done I think they've
been released at this point but they've
I got this last week so that means it
must be hitting stores in the next week
or two that compiled all the issues into
a really great looking book drawn by
pernil who came and visited us to do the
DC superhero girls line design so this
is in stores mr. mark Miller's company
good folks at image put this out and
it's a fun story that is insanely
reminiscent of Jay and Silent Bob strike
back in fact it's just the same [ __ ]
story so there's that now there's this
let's bring this out this as we all know
Ghostbusters recently celebrated their
35th anniversary this box got sent to me
on the side it says danger high voltage
1 kV electronic shock hazard removed
power before repair or adjustment
there's the logo on this side it says
Kevin Smith ain't afraid of no ghosts
which you know [ __ ] you I am don't speak
for me but this came from Jason Reitman
sent me an email and said hey I need
your address we did a Ghostbusters 35th
anniversary thing convention or weekend
someplace just rezoning Larson is that
where it was anybody go to it anybody
know about it you were invited to it but
a guy went you went how was it it what
did they do get him a mic hold on here
comes Jay C you'll get you a mic we had
somebody that attended
the Ghostbusters that they had a bunch
of the different ecto ones giant Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man more people in
costume that I've ever seen like almost
equal ratio of uniforms to civilians
it was great they had so do they bring
like a lot of fans and yeah as thousands
of people people came from all over the
country and I had to go was it free or
people have to buy tickets was i but I
had a friend whose painting doing a
light painting there so I you want happy
yes
so yeah but he was right there I bet you
Aykroyd was there Aykroyd
Ernie Hudson will Atherton I think that
was it but when I even in Jason Reitman
yeah and did I ever got up as well yeah
he didn't I heard and they showed that I
read like they showed footage showed
outtakes of the the first movie and like
alternate angles yeah of stuff that you
go oh can they cut that that's are you
serious the lines they were it was yeah
it was fantastic
well will the rest of us see that the I
think they put it on the blu-ray I want
to say mine hasn't arrived yet so I
don't know while we're here man let's
give it up for our man right here who
had a big sack though that's our man our
man we should shout out also as we've
got some inside dope on him right our
man just gave us inside dope we got some
inside dope on our man that's Nate and
Amelie ladies and gentlemen give it up
for Nathan hey guys
next week they're doing an event here
nathan has some very cool vinyl figures
that he's releasing and he's gonna do
his launch party here what are they
called
Roark's drawings and which is half robot
half bird we're going with that bird
yeah he operates the same way we do yeah
they are awesome man they're there are
exactly like I guess yes their drawers
you're right robots and birds for lack
of a better description when is the
release 8 p.m. on Friday June 28th but I
would recommend arriving early because
they're super limited yeah if you want
to get a set right on so we open at 6 so
you you know I'm not gonna tell you when
to get here but I'd get here before it
and when they go they go these editions
they'll be this one which is the
starfield Edition and a blueish one
that's the Carbonite that's also an
element that exists outside the Star
Wars universe
yeah SW this is so if you're all in the
area man was a week from Friday a week
from this Friday yes come on out get
yourself some drugs but before I let
them sit down I'll give them a man a
quick shout-out yeah if y'all if let's
do it this way anybody in this room and
this is not for my own ego but this is
just before I go forward in the story
anyone in this room familiar with a
motion picture called Jay and Silent Bob
strike back
the year is 2001 and we're trying to
fill a role in the movie
somebody had agreed to do it and then
couldn't do it they were trapped on
something else and so at one point the
casting director christine cheeks was
like well you know just who would you
love she's gone like you know if you
just whoo-hoo if you could put anybody
in the role like give me some names some
real pie-in-the-sky names and [ __ ] and
so I I wasn't like reaching for you know
modern-day the [ __ ] celebrities
because we had like Ben and Matt in the
movie and stuff like that I went from my
childhood heroes and whatnot so I said
what about this person
and you know I was like I've spoken
about this person's work and my work my
whole career maybe they might be
interested and they said we'll reach out
they reached out this person said yes
and did the movie and it's it even if
you don't like that movie people like
this sequence in that movie and
particularly when we did it thought it
was real [ __ ] great and stuff like
that the only reason that we got the
actor to come do that scene in the movie
because when they've reached out to the
actor the actor is like Jay and Silent
what now completely unfamiliar with my
body work which is absolutely [ __ ]
fine thankfully he had a kid who
actually knew about my stuff and
pressured his father to do the movie was
like you you have to do this even though
his dad was like I don't know what this
is and I don't really like doing things
like this because of Nathan right there
Mark Hamill played cock-knocker and our
movie
thanks to his terrible taste in motion
pictures
all right so Nathan was there that's
awesome thanks for that inside we didn't
even know we're gonna get that I think
man we got an inside report on the
Ghostbusters thing so apparently they
had a Ghostbusters thing at Sony and
everybody [ __ ] enjoyed it did you get
one of these did they say they didn't
just give them out to everybody let's
find out what it is so inside the box
inside the box look at the bog I'll run
I know I'm blocking myself but in order
to read hero John Doe has the upper hand
John Doe has the upper hand k-swiss
that's the sneaker company but also a
nickname of mine is to Ben Affleck used
to call me case with a Swiss I'm not
doing that scene again I was like all
right yeah k-swiss celebrates the 35th
anniversary of ghostbusters
with Footwear inspired by the ghosts of
the movie share with these hashtags to
be part of the celebration
hashtag Ghostbusters kind of makes sense
and hashtag I ain't afraid of no ghost
or which they said singular not plural
isn't it I'm afraid of no ghosts I was
30 flirt on nog host or what is it nog
host nog host that's true yeah I'm
available at footlocker com ghostbusters
exclusively at footlocker ok so that's
what's on the inside and we just made a
publicist very happy you're gonna break
everything down inside the box there's a
[ __ ] there's a pop of the scary library
ghost
then there is a what is this Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man
it says 35th limited and high res audio
it yes minidisc it's a Sony [ __ ]
Walkman and I didn't even do anything to
deserve it so I'm just catching me up
the Sony still make a Walkman just for
this apparently what you guys can't see
is there's like a thousand glasses right
under here that it seems as if he's
going to break at any given time you
just proved you don't need me
is the Sony I guess it's an mp3 player
and it says limited edition Walkman
right ansan on the back it keeps it says
everywhere not for sale
so I guess they made it just for this
and it's got the Ghostbusters insignia
for 35 you know like 60% less impressed
that it's not a legit [ __ ] Walkman
you know like I get it but wait a [ __ ]
in that first world way man I know for
the free [ __ ] that is discontinued I
would have rather the most archaic free
[ __ ] they could have given me naturally
there's a t-shirt involved of course
that says Ghostbusters and the the O is
replaced with the case with logo that's
what creates the oh now for the grand
reveal the sneakers
we'll find out what size they're okay
it's obviously made to look a bit like
the trap and it kind of opens like the
trap as well and inside holy [ __ ] it's a
pair of water what did would you call
this material those like jellies this
gently they're like jellies or whatever
yeah but they're very like like it's
it's a slimy green I guess and then
let's see the other one does it match
yeah it's the same thing so you got
yourself a couple Slimer sneakers man I
don't know what can you find a size yeah
right where this with the spider-man
suit nine and a half that's my size they
must have asked I don't remember the
masking or anything that's pretty dope
man I would put them on but it's gonna
take a long time I'm used to slip ons
yeah yeah he's got laces they defeat me
those so look at that man like Geoghan
what a bunch of cool stuff and whatnot
to celebrate ghostbusters but I remember
God bless you I remember the first time
I got something free because of my job
it would Walter Flanagan it was a Sega
Genesis I forget who gave it I was like
oh my god they gave me a Sega Genesis
and with [ __ ] such bitter division in
his voice man my friend looked at me and
it just goes the rich get richer
anyway that's my opening [ __ ] you saw
some stuff seen some [ __ ] in the world
what have you seen connect JC Kent could
we get some more out there's waters
right there never mind [ __ ] me okay
let's see I've seen two movies I saw the
Dark Phoenix picture I mean a movie
generously speaking like it has a
beginning in the middle and maybe an end
I don't know why did you go were you
like desperate to be alone in a movie
you're like I'm in this alone in two
movie theaters in gioco hosers I like
the space you know just just feel my
environment I mean cuz here's the thing
did it do it didn't do well it did not
do well at all
no it lost a bunch of money it opened
there like 24 25 million dollars that's
not good anymore not good anymore it's
not I'm never home anymore oh [ __ ] oh
you tell me well like the the Dark
Phoenix story is great like even from
the comics even if you break it down to
its its fundamental essence its Carrie
right like it's a girl with powers that
she develops after trauma and she goes
to see a doctor and the doctor finds a
way to get her past the trauma not by
helping her deal with it but by walling
it away you know but building these the
psychic barriers so that she doesn't
ever feel the pain but along with that
pain is her power and so as she gets
older as I like your breakdown of the
Dark Phoenix storyline that's pretty
pretty like compact its elemental right
and so as she gets older as she
experiences [ __ ] in the world whether
she experiences [ __ ] like space
storms or just regular earthbound trauma
those walls begin to break down and she
begins to realize not only who she is
really and what was done to her but it
was done to her by somebody who told her
that he loved her like I'm doing this
for you I'm doing this to keep you
better but the consequence of that is oh
so Charles Xavier is the bad guy this
movie right that would be kind of
[ __ ] cool no because he can be they
got over aliens who are the bad guys and
like magneto shows up for a while and
like kind of maybe wrestles a helicopter
to the ground with Jean Grey which when
you watch it it's just like
dudes doing this a lot and likes
training on their Facebook it's like
watching two telepathic people fight in
the movie we look like one bead of sweat
dress always disease in it now but so
the movies not that at all like the
movie is is you know Jean Grey is not a
touch with inner emotions and her
emotions are what makes a weak but
really they're what makes her strong and
magneto is like kind of in Genosha but
not really like doing weird [ __ ] in the
woods with a bunch of other mutants who
are off the grid and then like aliens
show up and they take over Jessica
Chastain's body for reasons that are
unclear and they turn into like Scrolls
but not really because they shape-shift
a lot and then and then they wait who's
who is just a good chest to implant and
alien who wants the Phoenix force for
herself but nobody no she's not Emma
Frost which is what you'd think looking
at that I remember when I cast her I was
like oh they recast this for us but it's
just it's it's big word and it doesn't
need to be big and it's small where it
could have been smaller and like you
could have just done this intimate story
about this woman coming to grips with
her past and the people who have wronged
her in her present but instead like
there has to be some giant [ __ ]
powered down where there's explosions in
for some reason there's a subway car on
[ __ ] Central Park West and that's
keeping people from crossing the street
the climactic battle of this movie is
crossing the street from Central Park to
Central Park West are you [ __ ] me
yeah I know that's what happens it's the
bar that low I can direct an x-men movie
I've taken my characters from behind a
counter to another counter next door man
that's kind of like after battle so yeah
it is not good it is not good
it's the kind of not good that feels
kind of appropriate for this to like
limp its way out of fox and back into
Disney and back into Marvel's hands like
they could have gone out [ __ ]
swinging like both barrels blazing but
instead it's just this incredibly
impotent version of a story that has
nothing but power yeah it feels like at
the end of the day words like they and
they knew the end of the universe was
coming so yeah like long before we did
those cats involved would have known
like oh [ __ ] Disney's bionis and this
would probably be the end just why not
go out like [ __ ] do whatever you do
let's tell the last x-men story and
what's strange is Simon Kinberg did the
the draft of the Last Stand x-men 3
which Brett Ratner directed that was the
original stab at the Dark Phoenix
storyline so he got a second bite at the
Apple by doing it on this this time
almost never happens yeah like that's
such a what do they call that a not a
MacGuffin like when you get a mulligan
I'm mulling yeah you do it again
the only other person that ever heard
who got that kind of Mulligan was
Michael Mann Michael Mann made a an NBC
TV movie called la takedown yeah which
is shitty and bad but he loved the
script so much he then became Michael
Mann and said I want to remake this
shitty NBC TV movie that I made and I'm
going to call it heat and I'm gonna cast
the most amazing actors in the world
we're gonna shoot the exact same [ __ ]
script that I wrote that made the shitty
movie and it's gonna be a classic
because now I have 50 million dollars
and De Niro and Pacino and so there's
you can go online and you can see like
sort of a B versions of like here's the
scene and the diner from LA take down
with like Steven Bauer and like some
other dude you've never seen before and
then here's the same scene with the same
lines with Pacino and De Niro and like
it's amazing to see what like actually
great actors can do with what is
ultimately kind of pedestrian dialogue
because you've seen it just done
horribly all right that's the only other
instance I can think of like one person
I mean like you know I want to do this
again
we didn't get it right the first time
I'm gonna get another shot at this Apple
Jay and Silent Bob reboot I always let
that sit there for a little bit this is
just marinated see yeah it's not great
that's the truth and you know nobody
wins when there's not a great comic book
movie out there because then it gives
like media pundits a chance to be like
is the comic book movie craze coming to
an end film at 11:00
did they do that anymore I don't know
I've seen people write that article over
and over again it's like just cuz
[ __ ] one doesn't do well yeah I mean
this this I mean spider-man's about to
come out and take everybody's [ __ ]
money right the narrative instead was
like sequels and prequels and reboots
and D boots and all those things are we
getting tired of sort of IP itis and you
know Dark Phoenix was was sort of
Exhibit A and men and black
International was Exhibit B that came
out as well that came out as well did
you see that - I saw that - do you not
have a job or something
do you constantly keep telling them I am
riddled with disease it requires
extensive care from a panoply of
healthcare professional is I just hired
a guy who's we're gonna be like mark and
it's like he went to the movies again
help some right wow man the man in black
also came out and I mean I have never
[ __ ] charming his phone I have never
seen two people have so much charisma
used to such ill effect oh no really
yeah he's [ __ ] funny he's looking at
funny he's funny he's charming she's
smart she's she's funny too
they're both funny and I like F gary
Gray quite a bit as a film he directed
the director he's talented he's super
talented the things he's not talented at
though is comedy I don't think we've
ever really liked after since Friday
direct Friday I was gonna say Friday
like everything's been kind of like
straight into Compton in Fast and
Furious agents
concentrate straight-up yeah you're
right dude steady oh my god I tried to
whites plain rap to you I'm like now now
let me tell you something she writes to
the [ __ ] with attitude were not enough
Compton sir it was Connecticut so yes
he's not been like the funniest dude
behind the camera in about 20 years and
up a Friday like counts as the Friday
counts probably funny movie but uh but
yeah like there's just that they're
using these two actors the wrong way
like Chris Hemsworth in this movie as
Agent H I think cuz Hemsworth I guess is
eh he's aged like he's a dick and like
not a dick who's like a charming dick
not like Thor is a charming dig like in
Ragnarok like that's the whole point of
it it's like let's make fun of this
handsome impossibly handsome impossibly
charismatic guy mm-hm I'm making him the
butt of every joke and that's what makes
that work this is like he's just walking
white privilege it's like I'm gonna be
bad at my job I'm gonna be hostile work
environment I'm gonna be smarmy and smug
and like a dude like why would you do
that to Hemsworth and then she's just
kind of like having to be both eager and
learned at the same time what's the
story the story is she when she was a
girl and this I think is in the trailers
her parents there was an alien in her
house like this little cute [ __ ] of
fluffy alien her parents get neuralyzed
she doesn't and so she spends the next
20 years trying to find the man in black
oh and so she does like she's super
[ __ ] smart she could have gone into
any any segment any section of the law
enforcement in the government that she
wanted to but she wanted to hunt aliens
and she finally finds them says I found
you like nobody else like you recruit
people all the time nobody's ever found
you that's gotta count for something so
Emma Thompson is like all right you're
gonna be a probational agent there's
trouble in the London bureau go and
sniff it out so they send
the rookie to London to go and figure
out what the problem is because Liam
Neeson hates black people not in the
movie just general I mean did you guys
miss did you forget that he just wanted
to like randomly kill black dudes one
time and like mention that to a reporter
like well promoting a film we all hit we
only know that because they were like
what was it like making this movie Liam
and he was like let me tell you told the
story that was incredible a friend of
mine got raped and so I just wanted to
kill every black person I saw for a week
I just went on the streets of Belfast
and tried to kill anyone would do that's
his [ __ ] quote I would just looking
to kill somebody and they just had to be
black so yeah so now in men in black
International and so he's like the head
of the London Bureau agent T they call
him high tea because it's British hmm
and and Liam Hemsworth is there like
Prince Charming like best agent in the
house except all evidence is like you're
bad at this like you're you you put
other agents in jeopardy like you're
risking like it's you're not a good
person at this job but we're supposed to
love him because he's Chris Hemsworth
and he can only do but so much and the
movie it's just missing the calibration
of Tommy Lee Jones was the grizzled
veteran and Will Smith was the dude who
like was astonished by everything like
and it was also deadpan and Matt that
dynamic is what makes that work it's the
here's the world you didn't know existed
here's the guy experiencing it for the
first time and him slowly realizing that
his corner unquote streetwise ways can
also be of service and also be an asset
in fighting alien immigration crime but
like it's just it without that dynamic
without the veteran and the newbie right
it just kind of sits there like people
who all know everything and just to have
discussions and command on Jionni plays
like a [ __ ] troll who like lives
Tessa Thompson shoulder and he's the
funniest part in the movie
not because he's funny but because he
understands that like if I speak in this
way it'll sound like it's supposed to be
funny and it'll kind of feel funny
even if it's not funny right welcome
alonandjenny just talking like he's he's
good enough at that to make it that
thing but it just it it just kind of
sits there and and you look at it you're
like no it looks good and the actions
fine and these people are handsome and
beautiful and charming but none of it is
being used to any good purpose mmm what
do you think happens next if I'm then I
make a [ __ ] men and black TV show
like yeah there you go
I mean I think you put it in LA like I
don't know said weather hasn't been a
minim black la you know like if you're
gonna be talking about immigration and
you gonna be talking about aliens like
why the [ __ ] wouldn't you do Southern
California and you get crazy [ __ ]
cameos but you know remember then they
have like famous people they always do
like up on the on the big metal wall
like Donald Glover like ah and there's a
little like there's a little like
there's a little Jay Jay in in
international like GCC's on the big
board at stage a room yeah it's cute but
yeah it's it's fine it's not good it's
not the worst thing I've ever seen but
it commits a cardinal sin of just being
fine
like mediocrity is like okay wait was so
better than x-men better the next man
and then at least it feels like it's
kind of a movie somebody object to that
thought that was very grumbly agreeing
no no I'm on your team but yeah it and
but the best thing that I saw this week
was this tiny show that's on HBO
that's executive produced by Lorne
Michaels and Fred Armisen called loose
Spooky's yeah Fred's show losses
Spooky's is my [ __ ] jam it is it is
is it all in Spanish
it is all in Spanish except for there's
a sequence where Fred Armisen plays the
world's best valet Parker and there's a
whole sequence where like you see his
mutant power of being able to park cars
unlike anybody else in the world but
when he is in like with the other valet
guys the the leader of the valets is a
black dude who speaking English and so
instead of subtitling in in English and
they're speaking Spanish they're
speaking English and they're subtitling
the Spanish so now they're Spanish words
in the bottom which is awesome but much
here--it there's this bit where because
it's for its for people they're all
friends there's a goth dude there's a
kind of twink chocolate fortune heir I
think is the closest there's a woman who
works in a dentist's office making fake
teeth and then there's a woman who does
not seem to feel pain who's the dentist
ladies of younger sister and so the they
get hired by a priest to help him fake
an exorcism because as a young priest in
the parish who's super hot that seems to
be super popular and so the old priest
is like the only way for me to get back
in their good graces used to do
something awesome right and so we're
gonna fake an exorcism and so and so he
hires these guys who like they had
thrown some birthday party a decapitated
heads and [ __ ] it's like you seem to be
good at this
can you stage it for me and the gay guy
on their way in he turns his buddies
like listen I was dropped off in an
orphanage when I was young and the
priest who's at this parish was the guy
who took me in and he hated me and I
hated him and he thought that I was
possessed by something but it turns out
I was just you know a colicky and
whatever was but if that's why the
priest doesn't like me that's why
and he's like blue hair like earrings
like it's not that I'm super gay it's
that I was left on his doorstep as an
orphan
it's so it's it's very like Napoleon
Dynamite lover like super deadpan super
straight ahead but I I just I kind of
love it it's so great is it multiple
episodes yeah it's half hour it's like a
sort of single cam sitcom on HBO on HP
so they're not dumping it all at once
week by week or should yeah yeah and
Fred's in at a bunch not a bunch I don't
I don't I don't get the feeling that
he's gonna be a main character they
might go to him once or twice you know
an episode if that but uh but no you
should watch it it's a man for fun I saw
him do a interview with Seth Meyers and
he was talking about it and he was
talking about how you know his accent he
always thought like amongst his white
friends he feels very fluent in Spanish
and then when he was working with these
kids they were like you don't talk your
accent is bad alright so that sounds
like that's something to look out for
yeah totally and I I think next week
we'll get a more into good almonds which
I saw the first episode of and really
liked yeah
but I got to dive deeper and Jessica
Jones that's right Jessica Jones is
drove the last of Marvel night we have
to see that a great lady off into that
good night because this is it for all
the Marvel shows and she's the last one
man yeah because remember how excited we
were when that all began and like
daredevil [ __ ] like made our hearts
leap that hallway fight sequence and
[ __ ] and then Luke Cage was better than
you imagined it would be and then iron
fist well it sucked but still like it
came out and you realize these [ __ ]
were mortal and then and then you know
they got back on track kind of with
other stuff but it's a shame it's the
end of an era but it's you know almost
the dawn of the era where they make very
expensive TV shows that are basically
movies as TV shows yeah for sure so we
got that to look forward to we do you
know what else we don't have to look
forward to tell me more Swamp Thing yeah
that [ __ ] one away damn quick
we talked about how they shortened the
season yeah they showed the season
unlike last episode we talked like I'd
loved the first episode yeah and then
like two days after the first episode
drama plot announced that we're Kansa
that the show's canceled they're only
doing that one season yeah so obviously
not about quality or we're fan
interaction because they barely released
yeah to make that decision seems like
that might have something to do with the
shifting landscape over Warner Brothers
and the new app that they're talking
about there's a bit of that because they
don't know if DC Universe is going to
continue going forward and so they're
not entirely sure how much money app
there yeah DC yeah like come on and [ __ ]
yeah and also that we talked about how
they built some giant stage for it like
that a soundstage in North Carolina and
they built a swamp and like so there are
some places were like 15 feet deep other
places we're standing deep but they all
of that stuff was all indoor somewhere
and storing that set was gonna be so
expensive that that contributed to the
like listen are we gonna really like pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
warehouse this set between seasons and
the answer was no I don't think so
Wow so yeah like it's sad because it was
a really strong show or at least the
first episode or two was really strong I
don't know how it has they released all
of them or they still beat them out yeah
so I'm diving in man because I keep
passing Warner Brothers the studio has a
giant he's the poster up for it and it
looks like the cover of an old Swamp
Thing Stephen Bizet cover I think heard
John Tolman cover gorgeous and and I'm
like wow they really [ __ ] got the
spirit of the show it looks like yeah
speaking of Warner Brothers for the last
three months or so JJ Abrams and bad
robot have been looking for a new
corporate home yeah they have their deal
at Paramount for features yeah yeah they
had a TV deal at Warner Brothers but
they in the era of the mega deal we're
like Berlanti was getting 300 million
dollars from Warner Brothers and
and Ryan Murphy got like 200 million
dollars from Netflix like that seems to
be the the sort of arms race of let's
find these mega producers and lock down
their services that robot was that
[ __ ] Magilla gorilla of them all and
so Apple one of them Netflix wanted him
and then Warner Brothers Warner Media
made their play and it seems as if a
wonder but morning media's gonna win
like it's some five hundred million
dollar deal for them to move everything
to one have they worked with Warner on
anything
TV was yeah West world is bad robot show
on HBO Castle Rock is a bad robot show
but yes so they they are in good with
Warner Brothers in general I also hear
according to The Hollywood Reporter one
of the deciding factors of where they
would go especially Warner Brothers was
if they got rid of Kevin tsujihara why
did they they they like Tim Bing uh they
wanted him gone I think the fact that he
was like me too captain of the world and
like negotiating with actresses for
roles in his office and on like party
yachts with Brett Ratner and like and
JJ's wife who runs that company Coburn's
bad robot she was like morality was we
will not sign a deal with you unless you
get rid of that guy and they got rid of
that guy
Wow and so so it looks like that's going
to be the move the interesting part is
suddenly you have JJ Abrams the the the
the foundry of remaking IP of overseeing
massive universes of characters and
Warner Brothers who currently has nobody
overseeing the DC Universe are you
that's just your eye that is just
conjecture but it would not surprise me
one whit if it was like hey man you know
who's awesome at doing this thing that
guy you know we have that needs doing
those guys and he'd be fantastic with
all that material yeah what a great job
he
after star wars is done to go [ __ ]
fix or just make more successful the DC
Universe and films that'd be pretty
magical and he has experience right he
wrote a Superman script he did years ago
whoo [ __ ] that made me very excited I
can tell I mean I was happy for I'm like
good for JJ a half a billion dollars
they'll be able to buy a new whatever
but but now I'm like oh good for me I
might get some good [ __ ] out of this
that's awesome [ __ ] I didn't know that
wait is that news are we in the news or
in the news are we segue to the news
look at that he's so smooth we didn't
even know Mark Barnard is taking us
through it give us more news what else
you got me saying so confident a minute
ago a like news maybe it's a good [ __ ]
off are you are you prepared for
comic-con [ __ ] no yeah of course I was
prepared for comic-con the day I was
born my friend yeah I can't wait you
know I'm busy as [ __ ] we've got the IMD
boat that I'll be interviewing people on
again I have a Hall H panel on Saturday
night where I imagine we might be
dropping a trailer I don't know
that's where we're gonna drop the
trailer and and those are the things
that I'll be doing down there plus some
you know other whatever like there's a
stand leave then this would be the first
comic calm without Stan so we're gonna
cite it in some way but yeah but so I'm
kind of set I'm ready what about you
getting there like the last week has
been a lot of scheduling and like
signings and panels and and all that
stuff so it's beginning to get into
shape which I I'm always a fan of yeah I
love comic-con so - just last year that
we got ink pots we did yes and that's
chairman mark one ink pot Awards which
they give they've only given out a
certain amount but it's essentially like
your comic-con royalty yeah for
contributions to the comic book arts yes
that's very nice pretty dough
and this year you know this year I'm an
official guest of the Comic Con it's its
50th anniversary this year so I got
invited as a guest like I'm there all
the time but they periodically like will
invite me and put me in the book and
[ __ ] like that and so this is I can't
take me to the third time I've been a
guest at Comic Con but a nice big year
to do it yeah very cool I'm not a guest
this year yeah you could be my guest
put my service to the test
oh my god
I just really alright try the white
stuff it's delicious don't believe me
ask the missus it can sing you can dance
I'm the dirty one all right what else
so yeah Marvel is coming back to San
Diego they're coming back to Hall age
they skipped last year yeah and so this
year they're going to show some [ __ ] and
we don't know what yet do we know
they're shooting Black Widow that is the
only safe assumption is that we might
see some Black Widow footage Wow
the fact that they're coming is good
news ma'am I mean they could bring all
the Eternals with them if they wanted to
they could announce their shang-chi if
they were ready for it
mm-hmm they've been meeting with a
couple of people Donnie Yen I think had
a meeting too old for shang-chi unless
it's like old shang-chi but yeah there's
this there's some [ __ ] they could do if
they wanted to do but it's nice to see
them gay and also they'll have the TV
shows to talk about Kevin Feige in
charge of those TV shows Disney Plus as
well so they'll be able to be like
here's an update on on Falcon and Winter
Soldier here's an update on what do they
call wan division 1 division and Loki
and Loki as well which they released
somewhere I saw a photo of him
production still of him in like 1970s or
80s New York where was it concept art
yeah yeah so is him in time in 1975
there's a Jaa's marquee so I'm sure
they'll be able to talk about that as
well but Warner Brothers meanwhile
announced they're not gonna go because
they're like Wonder Woman still that
were a year away so they're not ready to
show anything yeah they released that
poster and that image of her in the
golden armor but which was amazing but
they don't have anything like I thought
they might go with birds of prey but
apparently they're not doing that
they're doing it down there of Corti
I mean maybe they'll schedule a separate
birds of prey thing but like Warner
Brothers will not have their giant dog
and pony show in Hall H and it seems to
be like they're correct me if I'm wrong
but it looks like they're alternating
now it seems like DC is staying off
years that Marvel is dominant and Marvel
but didn't go last year and I'm sure
they're not like we're afraid of DC but
they're just like we don't have anything
to do
there's nothing worth going for but
they've also got was the d23 is that
that in August Disney's own Khan of
sorts where they're like look we don't
do it here we could do it here for our
fan base and stuff yeah so that's that's
happening
were you a Hunger Games fan dude you had
to be clever but no no not that I wasn't
like oh my god this [ __ ] but I'm like oh
all right it's kind of battle royale hmm
Suzanne Collins just announced with
HarperCollins no relation that uh if
there's a prequel novel coming out oh
I'm sure that'll make money
most likely set like 65 years before the
events of the first movie the first book
so long before Katniss is even born
before Katniss is even born so that you
don't have to pay Jennifer Lawrence to
come back remember the [ __ ] remember
what you loved about the Hunger Games
it's gone meet the hunger meet Katniss
is grandma this sounds a little bit like
it sounds like the Krypton version of
Hunger Games well I'm sure it'll make a
buck or two and Lionsgate is already
putting it into like pre-production
because they're not not making another
Hunger Games movie like [ __ ] we we don't
have much anymore yeah they're like
thirsty for Hunger Games can't make it
more Twilight's
only that [ __ ] anymore they got John
Wick's don't they they do that bears
it's theirs but John wick even on his
best day does he know hunger no [ __ ]
Hunger Games
yeah those movies were gigantic I mean
he'll be fine and they have Chris Rock's
remake of saw that's true yeah and has
he been talking that up lately no
nobody's heard anything new just like
he's doing it can't be happening do you
know who else was not happy with the
Game of Thrones finale
yes but it has to be somebody noteworthy
and that would be Jesus even Jesus was
like look I'm a man of peace but like
what the [ __ ] I didn't a lot of [ __ ]
this [ __ ] world ain't worth saving
take them all
I thought it was a little heavy-handed
that the dragon burned the chair there I
said
and when I say heavy-handed look at
these [ __ ] hands Circe herself Lena
Headey what yeah she came out she came
out and she said I will say I wanted a
better death yeah oh my god obviously
you dream of your death you could go in
anyway on that show so I was kind of
gutted but I just think they couldn't
have pleased everyone no matter what
they did I think there was going to be
some big come down from that climb but
when like the laid out to do shows like
yeah I wanted I thought that was chicken
[ __ ] to I know you can't please
everybody but that pleased nobody know
there wasn't a single person that was
like good I'm glad she was crushed by
rocks and we didn't even get to see it
and then they showed her the next show
and she still looked pretty like nobody
wanted that everyone was like oh my god
I want to see the Dragon Eater burger I
want to see her [ __ ] fillet anything
everything yeah bran should push her out
a window [ __ ] something man
so many people could elect a burr
comeuppance and instead it was the
ceiling yeah
see if she's not happy I don't blame her
that's that I'm still not happy I'm not
shaped anymore but yeah I've moved down
there are other things be upset about
but I'm going to read this only because
I'm very happy but the pun that I made
okay in this Lobo might get his own show
beau you cannot take this cheap
entertainment weekly' punster out of me
it's true but sci-fi is developing a
Lobo spin-off now for those who aren't
paying close attention Lobo makes his
first appearance this season on Krypton
yes he hadn't appear last season correct
and he looks like the lead singer of
Slipknot if I remember he is a look I
applaud this I can't believe that
[ __ ] Lobo has not been exploited to
the nth degree at this point at one
point he was DC's Wolverine yeah and he
could sell books and [ __ ] like that and
he's tailor-made for [ __ ] media for
TV show for a movie or something like
that he's good you know who should have
played him I know he's playing [ __ ]
Aquaman but yeah Momoa would have been
the perfect [ __ ] Lobo and maybe
that's what they could do between like
[ __ ] you know I'll do Aquaman I'll do
Lobo and I'll do Aquaman and Lobo nah
man and then they can meet and fight but
anyway so he hasn't have they started
Krypton season 2 they have
next week we will have a Krypton guest
in the house oh do tell explain seg L
himself Cameron cuff uh-huh we'll stop
by oh very nice job the star of the show
sweet super sweet big fan but he needs
he's in town doing press for it where do
they shoot that show Ireland I believe
Krypton
yes that's my boy
Nate's got a child's heart don't they
shoot it on Krypton how long does it
take the dailies to get here somebody
tell them the planets about to blow
alright so Lobo my good is own show does
work that was my I think that's smart
I mean whether and I haven't seen their
incarnation of Lobo I've seen what he
looks like I haven't heard or anything
but that's a an idea I [ __ ] support
and it also feels like that characters
being groomed for more like they might
finally realize oh we got something kind
of cool here man let's let's roll them
out in various media yeah and sci-fi is
looking for another comic book show
because they just killed happy happy got
cancelled oh that was Grant Morrison
show yeah how many seasons they get I
got two they got two and they they're
looking for another space show because
they're like killjoys I think is in its
final season as well okay so Lobo might
be there just silver bullet to hit both
of those birds the answers are all their
problems
yes what a world we live in where
there's gonna be a Lobo TV show crazy
wonderful his own show Bobo happen the
last bars bit of news okay um they're
making a dune show we talked about that
before right now wait a second they're
making a dune movie yes but they're also
making a dune show that will be
connected because it's it's
what's-his-name didn't even knew yeah
the U is directing the feature will
direct the pilot also they are connected
so it'll be like a spin-off of sir and
the show is dune the sisterhood it is
all about the benetiz roads oh [ __ ] yeah
which is super [ __ ] exciting because
if you know anything about doing the
Benitez's which are [ __ ] bad-ass yeah
and I've been plotting the the birth of
the that [ __ ] turned me on right
there especially QC was like quiz that's
chattering Oh perfect a little shimmer
perfect pronunciation man the sleeper
must awaken um my name is a killing word
I shall not fear fear is the mind killer
we can do this all day I know we're
supposed to do a commentary track about
doing and now maybe we should well it'll
be timely if we do it as the new tune
it's happening when is the dune movie
coming 2020 May 20 2008 undated but I
would have to guess where would we watch
this series on the forthcoming Warner
Brothers ah indeed so that's gonna be
how they like start hooking people yes
that's their Star Trek what's the Star
Trek show Star Trek discovery yeah
that's their Star Trek discovery yes
Amen man [ __ ] especially with him I
like him as a storyteller he's not
letting me down ya know denis villeneuve
oh I mean [ __ ] what was that movie the
arrival yeah Jesus
what an amazing [ __ ] movie that holds
up it seems like one of those movies you
watch first time like oh and then you go
like nah I can't ever watch that again
you could [ __ ] watch that every damn
day and still find something surprising
or new in it such great writing great
directing alright that's it that's it
that's it up remark you had a bunch of
the
okay
Before we jump into Q&A men real quick
we're gonna bring somebody out last time
we did the show a couple weeks ago in
the back alley we met this young lady or
Kristen and Kristen is on a mission and
I told her oh my god come [ __ ] tell
our audience because like it's you know
filming it so other people hear about it
and stuff because this is a cause I
think we could all get beyond Kristen
take it away what are you working on
since May 24th I have been walking from
La Brea to vine and back again on
Hollywood Boulevard petitioning to get
Carrie Fisher a star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame thank you doing the Lord's
work man now the born says where is
Carrie Fisher
it says where is Carrie Fisher and I
have people from cars screaming she's
dead and I'm like I know sign the
petition they know it's a Los Angeles
yes
the sign is supposed to get you to come
up and ask me about what it's about and
I'm always looking down at the blank
stars like where's Carrie Fisher's star
because I was cosplaying for tips up in
Hollywood square like a lot of you know
recent transplants from different states
I'm from Virginia and I needed money
yeah thank you
you're more enthusiastic about it than I
was out of towners come here and yeah
well if you have any kind of costume you
know you go up there and you take
pictures with tourists and you get money
and I did that because I had a sexy
Princess Leia costume I got hired like
to play Princess Leia at a bachelor
party in April and it was fun and I was
like I have this costume let me go up
here and see if I can make some money
and I was asking people where's carrie
fisher's star and i found out that she
didn't have one the next day I showed up
with a sign
I haven't stopped since wait a second
that's awesome
the biggest question I think we all have
is like is there money in the bachelor
party dress up yeah actually work my
bachelorette party when I marry Seth
MacFarlane but I why does everybody
laugh when I say that anyway yeah well I
should have asked for more money because
what I did was I put together a playlist
of Star Wars parody songs and I like I
was super method Carrie Fisher I was
like oh they want Carrie Fisher they're
gonna get like the most feminist
Bachelorette you know bachelor party
emcee ever and like I wrote joke intros
to the song I used to Weird Al songs of
course Yoda and the saga begins and
there's like a ton of parody Star Wars
songs on YouTube and it was fun and I
was just like dancing and I'm seeing the
party and at the end I felt like it was
like really poignant you know the forces
is love it's what really helps us evolve
and I wanted that to kind of be the
point of the performance that I gave
them and yeah I should have made more
money on that job but at least I got the
costume out of it you know and I started
this quest and every day I'm out on the
street with these buns little kids faces
light up when they see me and you know I
put my hands on my hips and I say to
little girls you know I was born a
princess but I worked really hard to be
a general
how can people help do they need to
physically sign of it yeah well I asked
the parents first I don't like anybody
younger kids how can these people help
how can money would be great yeah
because I have structured this project
where I'm paying myself $20 an hour I
have a public spreadsheet on my blog you
can see everything I'm spending on it
this is three jobs this is a costume
character petitioning and social media
marketing because if people don't pay me
I'm like that's fine can you share a
picture hashtag where's Carrie Fisher
let's just get the word out that she
doesn't have a star and you know
highlight the sexist inequity that still
exists within Hollywood and yeah it's
not paying the bills I'm gonna have to
get a job but I still I have to keep
going for those little girls who look up
to me they need to know that women can
get the same honors as men but we have
to struggle and starve and fight for it
I don't have to starve if you donate
some money though I mean and I'm going
to hire other people to long term this
is a non-profit startup where cosplayers
petition for women's rights issues and I
hired my first employee tonight to I pay
to do 20 bucks to follow me around the
camera so I can make like a YouTube
promotional video so like I have four
dollars left in my bank account but I
like used everything I possibly could to
like you know spread what I'm getting
what I'm making from this so that other
creative people have a chance to make a
difference in the world and I think
that's something that Carrie Fisher
would have supported and would have been
would have wanted to be a part of I hope
every signature gives me a new hope
I would imagine to with the late with
the new Star Wars coming this would be a
right time to you know the Hollywood
Chamber of Commerce has this role that
makes them wait five years after
somebody's dead before they'll give them
the star which is [ __ ] for two
reasons first of all they give them to
living people all the time second of all
this is Carrie [ __ ] Fisher this is
long overdue
so the petition is specifically to get
them to break that rule I want this to
be the Carrie Fisher rule to get them to
eradicate the five year rule
specifically for her dope man you are
doing the Lord's work man everyone give
it up for Chris or whatever so awesome
okay man now we come to the QA part of
the evening we do this is the part of
the show ladies and gentlemen were you
good folks get to be involved and I know
we got our normal booty to give out was
there something else we do we have Harry
Potter in the order of the Phoenix
tickets at the Hollywood Bowl June 29th
so a week from Saturday
two tickets to tickets for Hollywood
yeah it's yeah they show the movie with
and then the live orchestra plays to the
movie at the Hollywood Bowl how do we
get these tickets at the Hollywood Bowl
gave us free tickets mm-hmm
[ __ ] well I went last year to Star Wars
at the bowl yeah
[ __ ] awesome really so great just to
be able to imagine that Harry Potter
will do the same thing but to sit in the
Hollywood Bowl audience and when the
theme [ __ ] and the fanfare starts I'd
really pop their [ __ ] lightsabers and
the entire like Syme imagine wands up
will happen oh sure
and that's it's kind of beautiful
everyone's gonna be having their wands
that sounds like a good time all right
so wait that but we only have two so
we'll give that as a as a pair as a
question well how about both that's what
a good idea we've got three questions
and three tickets three sets of tickets
from our good full of friends at 4dx
Deacon and the folks that 4dx
always give us tickets to give out for
the Q&A if you've never seen a movie in
a 4dx theater what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you like the whole world is coming
to an end clearly if you read the news
get your ass into a 40x theater man
you're pregnant yeah as Tracy Morgan
tells us it is what a wonderful
experience and now as we're in the
summer movie season what a great time to
you know be sitting in a seat where they
spray [ __ ] in your face and [ __ ] and
you smell burnt rubber it's amazing 40x
theatres there they're here in Los
Angeles at LA Live where else they have
them Chicago or New York there's another
one in Southern California somewheres
where one apart and apart is that right
[ __ ] Wayne apartments we shot clerks -
you didn't ask but I told you all right
so there it is so what we'll do is we
have three questions each question asker
if they ask a question good enough gets
a pair of tickets to 40x but of the
three question askers the best question
of the night gets the Hollywood Bowl
tickets so normally there's not so much
judgment involved but tonight
[ __ ] gonna be judged really
hard and [ __ ] so well and you know what
we'll take it out of our hands we'll
leave it up to the audience
so yes right [ __ ] this gonna this is
like one of those reality game shows and
[ __ ] what we'll do is we'll say you know
question one and everybody applause
whichever has the loudest applause they
win the tickets that way nobody gets mad
at us yeah diplomacy
I'm alright JC do you have the tickets
just find me after the show it'll be a
phone call
oh speaking of after the show fine Nate
you see this beautiful pin right here
says fat man beyond we have them
available man
if you love the show what the [ __ ] go
buy a pin goddammit
Nate's got a bag of about 50 of them and
they're ten bucks a pop grab them from
Nate and [ __ ] where your fat man pride
right on your [ __ ] lapel okay
JC as the owner of this here
establishment we always trust him to
reach into the audience and find the
bravest souls he's found one what's your
name man my name is Johnny Johnny Johnny
everyone give it up for Johnny man
sweep the leg Johnny what you got for us
John well first off thank you gentlemen
I appreciate everything you do as I'm
sure everyone in this room does so thank
you for doing what you do thank you
thank you so I'm gonna ask a question
and then I'll kind of give an example is
what I'm saying so my question is if you
could bring back one actor or actress
who has passed for an upcoming comic
book movie adaptation who would you
bring back so for my example I would say
Orson Welles like Citizen Kane style for
kingpin that would be my example that's
good pull yeah thank you
okay do I get to go for him absolutely
whoever's ready first I'm gonna go first
Alan Rickman Doctor Doom [ __ ] yeah
could you imagine his ability to a mote
from behind a [ __ ] still mask you
know what I'm saying like it was a
little good that performance would ooze
out of whatever [ __ ] metal they put
in front of his face you would feel it
and oh what a dream [ __ ] now I'm mad
we're never gonna see that I've - ooh
John Cazale as the vulture oh holy [ __ ]
Wow John Cazale for those Fredo Fredo
yeah who only made three movies
dear hunter and of the bank robbery was
Dog Day Afternoon
yeah and was nominated for Oscars in all
of them and then passed away I could do
things I'm smart you're my kid brother
Mikey and Laurence Olivier as Clayface
oh wow wow would you which play face the
actor the one that was with yeah yeah oh
that's [ __ ] good yeah what a got
Mysterio but we're getting us dude yeah
can I go again for more please please
keep going well I say these are pretty
quick so please go as much as I remember
reading I still have this Starlog and I
reference it quite a bit yeah there was
an issue of Starlog magazine that had
returned the Jedi on the cover and
that's why I bought it but inside there
was an interview with Tom mankiewicz who
was essentially the author of many James
Bond movies but Superman the movie and
so he didn't get the credit Mario Puzo
got the credit and the other two but he
got creative consultant but like the
word is that and dick Donner said it
himself Tom mankiewicz is responsible
for like whatever you love about that
first Superman movie the two of them got
together rescued Superman from like the
hands of people who are like let's let's
do this let's do that make it really
campy and stupid and silly and these two
guys for whatever reason like dick down
are not even a comic book guy but was
just like I this is an American icon
like this is [ __ ] this is the
hamburgers apple pie the [ __ ]
Cadillac you can't [ __ ] up Superman so
even though the dude wasn't like I've
been reading Superman my whole life he
was just like I know enough that like
this gigantic [ __ ] script is stupid
we need to tell a righteous story we
need to tell the story and the way to
crack the code is through him and Lois
Lane and stuff and those guys came up
with what is the template for almost
every [ __ ] superhero movie that
followed or every superhero TV show like
we're still all [ __ ] borrowing from
dick Donner's Superman Tom mankiewicz
gave this interview in Starlog where he
just talked about this possum
Batman movie in the future mind you the
cover date of this is 1983-84 or
something like that Tim Burton's Batman
wouldn't happen for another five years
so Tom mankiewicz discussed a period of
time where Warner Brothers after the
success of Superman was like maybe we
should take a crack at Batman and the
Batman that they were putting together
sounded like [ __ ] insane and amazing
Bruce Wayne / Batman Bill Murray and not
as a campy comedy version like Tom
mankiewicz was selling a very straight
version of Batman a serious version his
Joker was Peter O'Toole who wouldn't
that be [ __ ] up and it was the idea of
the sad clown so everything was
delivered very theatrically but he was
just he was not cackling and [ __ ]
what were the other [ __ ] ideas I
remember reading that as a kid and be
like we could have seen a Bill Murray
Batman and [ __ ] and just the way he
described the Batman is kind of what
they wound up doing and he was not
involved in Tim Burton's Batman but he
eventually got to it so years before
even Dark Knight Returns came out in
comic book stores which is kind of the
rebirth of Batman and how we get to Tim
Burton's Batman they were talking about
let's do a serious version of em and not
can't be like the TV show they knew the
TV show had the audience and that's
where everybody mostly knew Batman from
in the mainstream but they had this
vision about taking the character back
to his darker [ __ ] roots years before
that would eventually happen so that
notion of Peter O'Toole as the Joker
always captured my imagination like I
loved Nicholson's job and Heath Ledger
did a great job and whatnot you know it
cesar romero the [ __ ] classic joker
and then like and jared leto has been
great in other movies but the
no and jared leto was absolutely fine
absolutely fun joker and stuff as well
with delicious because you never do that
my [ __ ] job I know I feel so bad
already my Catholic guilts kicking in
and [ __ ] like that's Jordan Catalano man
like buzzing so in any event like the
idea
all those Joker's are great the idea of
Peter O'Toole
playing the Joker like still to this day
just makes me go like [ __ ] why didn't
we see that like and that was somebody
talking about doing this [ __ ] the way we
all treat it now seriously the way the
studio is treated now seriously long
before it's kind of a visionary take on
it before the visionary take the Tim
Burton ad so I would say the peter
o'toole joker if we can [ __ ] and raise
him and be like one more role and he's
like I was in heaven you [ __ ] but
we're like but you get to play the Joker
he's like oh this is worth it you know
we're gonna have to content ourselves
with what's his name Joaquin's Joker
which looks phenomenal I have one more
go go I could kind of do this all day I
think you're gonna win the tickets I'll
be honest David Bowie as Morpheus oh oh
come on give it up that's [ __ ]
ridiculous come on Wow Sandman Sandman
not like your red pill blue pill
Morpheus that's weird
now [ __ ] that sounds good what a great
question you definitely won 40 X tickets
give it up for him ladies a jungle thank
you
so job pleasure man pleasure
we'll see [ __ ] that was
what about what Whitney Houston as
Catwoman what yes you know what not
[ __ ] bad man I forgot like she'd
acted like bodyguard Waiting to Exhale
wow man
and clearly she knows from the
preacher's wife as well yeah and she
knows some demon she's know some demons
all right wait all right this is one
more of a sentimental favorite if I
could bring back any actress and caster
in a role Carrie Fisher general Leia
Organa
oh one more time boy now we're getting
sentimental all right hey man what's
your name hey my name is Justin hey
Justin Justin I start today 3:00 a.m. in
Seattle and Here I am to see you guys
welcome Justin or Dustin Justin's joj
Justin welcome man I had this question
all lined up where Z value if you guys
could be on the show together you know
but I'm gonna play on a question from a
couple of weeks ago but you guys kind of
blew that up so thanks for that but I
have a question um we just finished
avengers endgame wrapped up ten years of
marvel movies great superhero movies all
of them most of them I'm I'm really
interested in the idea that maybe there
could be a super villain team-up movie
that could actually be a really
excellent movie and you know maybe
starting with the Joker and building
towards something or maybe a completely
different IP so I'd like to hear both
your opinions on if you think there's
like a super villain team-up movie that
could really kind of have the input
maybe not the impact the Avengers but
could really carry a couple of years
worth of movies along I mean villains
are hard because I mean other than like
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid and
like Ocean's eleven it's hard to think
of villains who work in concert to do
anything because they're all [ __ ]
like greedy antisocial Psychopaths
so like team of those people always
feels a little wonky I mean you could
probably do the Legion of Doom and have
a good time with it
I mean you could at least do like Luthor
Lex Luthor and the joker like world's
finest essentially where Batman and
Superman aren't your main characters
Luthor and the Joker are right like
that's a way to do it what Marvel
characters could you Marvel villains
could you team up I mean you could do
the Hellfire Club yeah yeah and I think
that that kind of works I think because
it's less a collection of a bunch of
equal stature bad guys and more like
huge and affront collective of truly you
will ruffle in the strings in the
background kind of thing hmm
you know Hydra stranded does that
sinister sinister six which they teased
you know and over at Sony and they might
eventually get back to I mean like they
had great success with venom into the
spider vs. did very well obviously we're
all excited about far from home so it
feels like Sony is on a right track and
maybe they do get around to like oh
here's our version of the Sinister stay
well there there were team ups like
Shazam's villains would team up back in
the day and you know so maybe they could
go somewhere with this damn print oh I
mean black Adam obviously poison ivy
there you go
well they're kind of doing that right
well not poison Ivan Harlequin Badou in
Harley Quinn and birds of prey who else
is in it what are the other female
characters Huntress Black Canary is
Catwoman oh I can fuse my fishnets power
girls got her show coming who Cassandra
Cain she's also in birds of prey oh
that's right
I would uh I just watched Monster Squad
again
yeah so far the best villain team about
scene is Monster Squad
hmm I don't want to let this go
I want to think of more suggestions lead
you to do I mean of course like I would
[ __ ] love a legion of doom
anything particularly yeah they can
carry a [ __ ] movie especially if like
the heroes are in it you got to have the
heroes but they're just not the main
character it's basically the adventure
from the other side of the table and
let's be honest like villains are
generally more interesting anyway I
think so yeah like a good Suicide Squad
movie which is coming that would be
great just give me one of those
but like the good version the have you
read anything about that not really I
okay other than a dresses in it but not
please anybody know who the villain is
for Suicide Squad alright I do and I
just don't I can't say it them because I
thought everybody knew and I was about
to say oh my god they're gonna and then
I was like wait I might have heard
you're gonna break something I'm happy
I might heard that privately it I can't
I'm not gonna spell it but the if if it
is what I heard it is [ __ ] phenomenal
and it boy is it in the right hands oh I
forget where I heard it I know it wasn't
a dream but I heard that and I was like
[ __ ] oh no I didn't you know I did
hear it's legit and I can't talk about I
think we all know Dave de small chin
who's a friend of the show and he's in
Jay and Silent Bob at reboot as well
Dave we know he's been cast in the
Suicide Squad movie did they announce
who he's playing I don't think they did
they did okay so he's playing polkadot
man so I believe Dave told me who the
villain was with like you careful could
say anything and I was like I won't he's
like don't accidentally say it a fat man
beyond I was like I
but he said yeah that's why I got and it
says he's legit he's red like that crazy
quilt no I'm not no that be all believe
me if it was I'd be telling you but no
it's much much cooler it's fantastic and
and Manmohan Tai heard this I was a [ __ ]
that's genius
the team is kind of different as well
like all of it sounds like a good
[ __ ] time and I liked Suicide Squad I
wasn't one of those people that [ __ ] on
I enjoyed it
but [ __ ] this sounds amazing his
incarnation but dude you just [ __ ] on it
was a little bit of shade then I kind of
pulled the back loop yeah it was like a
web he's not the whole movie you got to
be fair it was a wet fart it wasn't a
full-on [ __ ] it was just a drive-by
there's a bit of a shark yeah
alright that was [ __ ] good we got
good [ __ ] out of a get over mana anyone
to take ass pleasure
JC another victim what's your name hi my
name is Jessica everyone give it up for
Jessica so the big thing this last
couple of years has been universes so my
question to you is what universe have
you been dying to see whether it be in
TV or movies or video games like my
personal favorite what would be an ideal
universe to you that you wish that they
would just do a moral one
no too much soap for let's see what
would I like to see what universe
haven't they [ __ ] touch because lord
knows everybody's grabbing everything up
I'm not gonna have to give multiple
answers because I'm gonna think about my
entire life right now and all the things
that I've liked crossed that lifetime
and a lot of things you know are still
in the Bo mainstream in vogue like Star
Wars one but when I was a kid
pre Star Wars I had romances with stuff
I was a big fan of Snoopy so I'd love to
see the peanuts universe like [ __ ]
done insanely well but I think they're
doing that over at Apple from what I
understand Apple bought a big stake in
the peanuts I've read and I gotta be so
[ __ ] careful it's mice thrown out
information that I assume everybody
knows and then I'm like wait I just hear
that
who's making [ __ ] peanut yeah yeah I
think I think I was in the press yeah
sure was um so there I think I hope so
it looks like that'll be coming alive
here's something I really liked and I I
know they're trying they've been trying
to [ __ ] do it and I had a run at it
and stuff and sooner or later somebody's
gonna do it but the title is a real nut
biter but still the Six Million Dollar
Man
the idea of Steve Austin astronaut we
can rebuild him like that [ __ ] [ __ ]
is made for a multiple that's what
they're working on now supposed to be a
Marky Mark's movie and it's called the
six billion dollar man cuz inflation but
but like all that [ __ ] tracks right he's
[ __ ] you know an astronaut or a test
pilot who gets in a [ __ ] rack and like
he's gonna die we gotta save him and now
bionics is even more plausible in [ __ ]
when when that show was on we were kids
is based on a book called cyborgs when
that show is on we were kids that was
like the 70s it was like could you
imagine if a human had a [ __ ] robot
heart and [ __ ] land that would happen
like 10 years later so maybe you know
the idea of a cybernetic organism is no
longer fun to anybody in
but I think there's poignancy to that
story and I think like it's got a
universe man it's got Jaime Sommers
Oscar Goldman and that's it there's only
three so uh do you feel that maybe more
suited in a TV setting or a yeah that to
me feels like a TV show but I know
they're trying to make a six billion
dollar man movie and again with Marky
Mark it's kind of plausible but I would
personally do it a neat show you're in
for the Marky Mark II totally because of
Marky Mark or just alone has he done
like Oh transform yeah but transformed
you guys at the end of transform ah it's
[ __ ] up the miss Brawne you guys so
how do you love it for me have they they
this week in the news or maybe the last
two weeks in the news I've seen some
Keanu Reeves like Marvel stuff you've
been saying that rumors Keanu Reeves
like is that what it is it's for sure
the Eternals look I'll see anything they
do confirmed by Johnny in the corner I'm
there for anything they do but that's
like you know naturally I hear Keanu
reason like oh my god they got to make
him some character that I know but like
they're like no we're gonna make them
someone you don't know and probably
don't remember and that's smart because
that'll attract people to somethin that
doesn't have like this one I'm not
saying it's a test but like then doing
the Eternals is like yeah yeah the
journals alright I trust you but that
ones that's even deep cuts for me so I'm
there for whatever they do but like I
guess it makes sense to like put Keano
in that put what's her name in it
Angelina yeah they're gonna need to pack
that I think with some stars so that
people are like what is this because it
doesn't have the built in like the
Eternals takes place like thousand years
before I guess but neither did guardians
when we got guardians that's why I'll
never [ __ ] you know I'll never be
like big can't do this they put they
announced guardians I was like that was
one of the worst comic books
read I said I can't believe they're
[ __ ] doing this they have so many
other characters will have a [ __ ] and
then that's one of my favorite movies
ever made so you know in the right hands
anything could be wonderful but I just
don't have any I'm not I'm there in the
bag for him but there's no part of the
Eternals that touches my childhood where
I'm like oh I've always wanted to as a
god that's a book I avoided you know so
I look forward to the movie in a big bad
way but yeah I've seen some Keanu Reeves
stuff I was I was kind of hoping it was
for something more like what he's gonna
play Norman Osborn but no it sounds like
he's gonna play it in the Eternals
speaking of Norman Osborn man you think
we get a Green Goblin in this new
spider-man University you think they
stay away from it because we've done we
had in spider-verse yeah a little touch
yeah little tots big giant [ __ ] touch
but but I mean in the Tom Holland
spider-man movies like so far we've had
vulture and now we're getting Mysterio
in a world where we're heading or hoping
for a sinister six they gotta at least
get three of them out there in a movie
before making three you know bringing
three new ones in I think I think before
we get Goblin again you get da cop again
oh we got I mean a doctor
Octavia yeah and look I'm not
discounting into the spider verse but
they're not necessarily going these
things are [ __ ] tied together it's
like yeah they're all tied together but
I'm just talking mostly about the
live-action franchise at this point the
well who would it be if it wasn't if you
weren't doing Green Goblin he's got like
one of the richest [ __ ] rogues
gallery deepest benches in comics like
it's Batman and [ __ ] spy mean there's
Kraven the hunter there's you can bring
the [ __ ] Punisher back for real if
you wanted to you could I mean but we've
seen it we've seen it done insanely well
and stuff on TV and also it's you know
the spider-man movies are pg-13 right do
we really want a counter sure in the
pg-13 movie and sure
where he's like I'm gonna f him up Peter
you know joy you can't protect him Pete
what uh what other spider-man villains
Rhino kingpin
yeah I'd cross kingpin over into the
movie University was so [ __ ] good
yeah that's true that performance was so
[ __ ] layered textured amazing so much
work went into it is a shame where they
only got three seasons out of that and
he was really only in two seasons he was
in one episode in season two if I
remember quickly or maybe two but yeah
he didn't get enough time with that
character he certainly had more time
with the character than Michael Clarke
Duncan ever got but as far as I'm
concerned that performance you could
have [ __ ] done a whole show just
about him it was so on point it was so
like disturbing I saw him describe it in
an interview one point where he was like
he's a man-child like he's he's you know
a guy he's a kid who's trying to pass as
a man and when she don't go his way what
do kids do they just throw tantrums you
just really sympathize with him you did
and at the same time you were [ __ ]
horrified by as well like it was a
really fantastic maybe one of the best
Marvel villains of all time like hands
down is that performance so the peanuts
universe that was a great question and
we got great answers give it up for I
didn't answer oh [ __ ] I was still in
love with my own responses as I was like
nevermind
you're my favorite part of this you know
what do you what do you think I'm still
partial to that idea we had like three
years ago for a World War Seuss yes
that's true cross over every Seuss
character overall the Seuss characters
in that world we should do the serial
movie too he crossed over all the serial
pitchman and [ __ ] yeah ask the Trix
rabbit [ __ ] fighting lucky the
[ __ ] Lucky Charms up the ass and
Count Chocula sucking blood but I've
makin monsters like Frankenberry I think
I would I would like to see like a real
good for real version of Greek mythology
I think the original universe I think I
think you go all the way back and [ __ ]
Zeus and Hercules and Apollo and all of
that [ __ ] it's also by the way IP that's
not owned it belongs with everything we
all own it so anybody could start their
own Greek yeah but I just called it so
it's mine I'll go in the alley and pee
on it so you guys can plug it yes oh
yeah that's that's what I did World War
Zeus and in the Pantheon Greatest
American Hero
yeah but I mean weren't they did she
were just about to do it last season
right like the girl version yes yeah and
then they were like yeah we're not gonna
do it after all yeah that could easily
be redone well I like that is there
anything else are there any others
Robotech but that doesn't mean anything
to me
I mean I'm going over my childhood could
you do like a like a Thundercats
Silverhawks kind of like all of those
like Filmation like yes 80s cartoon
crossovers like I think they're talking
about doing masks aren't they it was
connected what's his name Jojo right to
G I joke with John Sena Cena Cena who
was in bumble bee he was meant to be in
and they may still be doing it but a
character that crossed world so he was
gonna be in masks and what and which was
the other one what mask GI Joe and
transform yeah like why haven't they
done a GI Joe transformers crossover I
mean it seems got to be imminent right
because transformers is not certainly
not on the ropes but like the franchise
is now seen its biggest days now it's
time to team it up with another
franchise which is also seen its biggest
days and be like Ollie [ __ ] that yeah
transformers Fast and the Furious oh my
God all those fast the viewers fools
jump in their cars they transform and
kill them in the cars just blood seeping
out a little bit like DOM is dead like
oh yes Wow [ __ ] that was fun that was
good a good question and you did
eventually get to good answer
give it up for a lady's job she wanted a
yes well done pleasure denied no worries
no worries no worries
alright we heard three questions we've
got one set of Hollywood Bowl tickets to
see Harry Potter to give away two what
was the best question of the night I'm
not gonna inform this boat at all I'm
just gonna read off or say one two and
three and then you'll all make the
decision without me
how do we do this let's go backwards
number three
those universes we wanted to exploit
yeah question number two was villain
team-ups number two okay question number
one was back from the dead back from the
dead excellent [ __ ] question god what
a [ __ ] fun show man unfortunately
well done thank you great stuff [ __ ]
yeah
this is the worst part of the show when
it's over man we got nothing left to
talk about but what's this
I saw that
so zendaya is I guess they're doing
press over in England for far from home
or something so she put up I saw this
earlier today she put up on Twitter
maybe Instagram as well a photo of
herself and her hair is red like Mary
Jane's and she wrote like face it tiger
which is the famous line when you open
the come face hit the jackpot really
great picture if you've not seen it take
a look at it she didn't do that in the
movie that was just for like the press
junket yeah but it looked [ __ ] pretty
cool it was a nice homage and whatnot
that's happening very soon when does
that happen spider-man July 2nd so where
are we right now what's the day there's
only like two weeks left [ __ ] I can't
wait what happened we're here July 2nd
we have a show when is speaking of which
housekeeping do we have another show on
a week from now the 25th and then July
2nd so the next two shows next week this
time then July 2nd tickets at cease
Montcalm but July 2nd show is probably
when we'll be able to talk about
spider-man presumably we will have seen
it by then maybe or I've got an early
invite of you me neither but I might go
that day oh right before yeah you bought
like a 5 o'clock show but like the
ArcLight
I got to go to the [ __ ] Avengers
premiere because of Chris Hemsworth but
I thought it'd be weird to call him up
and be like can you get me spider-man
tickets too
he's like I'm not a scalper mate but
yeah I don't know if we will be seeing
it early but that definitely will be
talked about what if we tried to
organize
I mean I'm gonna yell at you and tell
you will you tell everybody we already
sold
I think there's 30 tickets but what if
we tried to organize like like a mini
spoilers like hey we're all gonna go to
the ArcLight to the 3 p.m. show of far
from home and then come back here fair
enough yeah we can totally do the do the
do the show this dubs membership member
and some AMC publicist out there just
like did they just [ __ ] say Stubbs
that's awesome I got a stubby they said
all right so wait so will firm up
details but it could be it's a wait
that's a what day is Tuesday Tuesday and
lens that come out that Tuesday that
Tuesday why is it a command on of cousin
Sue's July for the weekend so it'll be
second third fourth all right so the
idea we'd probably go to like what time
is our show at night as usual yeah so
show seven eight we go over a year to
three rocks rock show all right we'll
shore up details but that sounds [ __ ]
fun and anyway we could just make it
open to everybody but we're not paying
by the way [ __ ] you everybody's agree in
a free movie no you're not
we can all meet there and [ __ ] go
that means even people that aren't
coming to the show here if they just
want to [ __ ] do that and they will be
playing like every half an hour on the
half an hour so we can go whenever you
want you know we could we could
I mean how many people we generally do
about it was this 80
yeah 80 I mean if somebody wants to do
the air view belongs if somebody wants
to do the research Nate you JC fine like
a [ __ ] there's got to be a hundred
cedar in this town that we can rent out
I'll just pay for it and everybody could
[ __ ] it come we'll do that like
100 seater can't be that much although
maybe on opening day they like [ __ ]
yes he's gonna be a lot of money but I
did that once before I did it was on a
Monday though I think like I was doing a
QA in Kentucky and changing lanes had
just come out and then a flex movie was
offered to buy out a screen for changing
well I mean I told everybody's likely to
show up and I'll [ __ ] buy tickets and
[ __ ] and I honestly because I told them
I was like it's playing at 10 a.m. I'm
gonna go see it at 10 a.m. tomorrow
whoever comes up I'll buy tickets and
you know I thought maybe two or three
people show up it's [ __ ] 150 people
showed up but I was like here's my
credit card
me and my big mouth so we can do that
again man we're at like a hundred seater
out and and but we'll find out we'll
know by next week's show we'll be able
to call that lark light and Chinese are
they walkable and maybe someplace
cheaper than that but yeah this premium
tickets there man I mean you might as
well suggest we do it at a forty x
theater which actually would be the
[ __ ] move man yeah to pay for it Oh
40 X let's find out like gasps Deacon
maybe there's a hike yeah gotta go
downtown LA Live yeah for a free movie
in a chair of the jerks you all
everybody wants less whoops everyone yes
she webs like crazy all right we'll work
on that and Shore it up next week with
more details but in the meantime [ __ ]
the future let's live in the present
y'all have a good time tonight
I want to thank the folks who gave us
the Ghostbusters stuff the case whiz
Ghostbusters package that was fun to
open up the folks that gave us the
Doritos folks with the spider-man
incognito Doritos promotion that was
[ __ ] fun to open up and [ __ ] but most
of all I want to thank the guys standing
in my left without him we have no
[ __ ] show as you heard give it up for
mr. mark Klein and that is fat man on
Batman for this Batman Beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I am NOT Bernardo tune in next
time same bat time same bat Channel so I
guess I got more youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
you